Bonjour à tous ! Aujourd'hui, une courte vidéo
pour vous annoncer la sortie
de mon nouveau livre, le 2ème en fait,
qui s'appelle "Insoluble MAIS VRAI !",
qui sort chez Flammarion le 31 mai.
C'est un livre qui est consacré aux grands problèmes
non résolus de la science,
ce que les scientifiques appellent souvent les problèmes ouverts.
Des problèmes non résolus en science, il y en a plein
évidemment, c'est le travail des chercheurs tous les jours,
mais parmi tous ces problèmes
non résolus, il y en a quelques uns
qui jouissent un peu d'un statut particulier,
soit parce qu'ils ont une importance vraiment
fondamentale dans leur domaine,
soit parce que certains ont une importance historique.
Il y a certains de ces problèmes non résolus
qui sont là depuis des décennies voire des siècles
et qui résistent toujours.
Il y a aussi certains de ces problèmes
qui sont particulièrement fascinants
parce qu'ils ont l'air très simples en apparence
et pourtant ça peut faire effectivement des décennies
que les chercheurs se cassent les dents dessus.
Fidèle à mon habitude, j'ai décidé de parler
d'un peu tous les domaines de la science,
donc je parle de physique,
notamment de physique fondamentale,
par exemple, qu'est ce qu'il s'est passé
avant le big bang, problème non résolu.
Je parle de biologie, par exemple, pourquoi est-ce qu'on dort ?
Et bien oui, aussi incroyable que ça puisse paraître,
on ne sait pas vraiment,
on ne comprend pas pourquoi on a besoin de dormir.
Je parle aussi de mathématiques, par exemple,
comment sont répartis les nombres premiers ?
Puis je parle de sujets qui, pour certains,
sont assez fondamentaux,
d'autres peuvent des applications technologiques
ou médicales assez importantes,
par exemple, comment fonctionne la supraconductivité
ou alors pourquoi est-ce qu'on vieillit ?
Si on comprenait mieux pourquoi on vieillit, ça permettrai
certainement de faire des progrès, notamment en médecine.
A part les classiques maths, physique, bio,
j'aborde aussi un peu de géologie, un peu d'algorithmique,
aussi un peu de linguistique donc j'essaie
de traiter un peu tous les domaines de la science.
Deux questions qu'on me pose souvent
au sujet de livres comme ça,
la première question c'est le niveau du livre.
Alors c'est à peu près le niveau, on va dire,
de ce que je peux faire en vidéo sur la chaîne,
c'est-à-dire que ce n'est pas un livre qui est destiné
à des jeunes enfants, par exemple,
mais ce n'est pas non plus un livre qui s’adresse à des gens
qui auraient fait des études scientifiques poussées.
C'est un livre pour le grand public
qui s'intéresse à la culture scientifique.
L'autre question qu'on me pose souvent, c'est le rapport
avec ce que j'ai pu faire en vidéo sur la chaîne.
Alors vraiment, je vois ça comme deux choses indépendantes,
c'est-à-dire que le livre n'est pas du tout une reprise des
scripts de ce que j'aurais pu faire en vidéo, pas du tout.
D'autant plus que moi, à la base,
j'écrivait avant de faire des vidéos,
je suis plutôt quelqu'un qui vient
de l'écrit, donc ce n'est pas du tout ça.
A l'inverse, je ne me suis pas censuré
si j'avais envie de traiter dans le livre,
un sujet que j'avais déjà traité en vidéo,
c'est-à-dire que je n'avais pas envie de faire l'impasse sur
un problème que je trouvais très beau ou très important
sous prétexte que j'en avais déjà parlé en vidéo.
Il y a un certain nombre de problèmes qui font un lien
avec des choses que j'ai pu traiter en vidéo,
par exemple, sur les nombres premiers
ou sur de la physique fondamentale,
donc voilà, je vois ça comme deux choses indépendantes.
Le livre sort chez Flammarion,
il a été illustré par Lison Bernet avec qui
j'avais déjà travaillé sur le premier livre,
"Mais qui a attrapé le bison de Higgs ?",
Lison a fait de supers illustrations sur chacun des chapitres.
Le livre sort le 31 mai donc au moment où sort cette vidéo,
normalement il n'est pas encore sorti,
mais vous pouvez déjà le trouver en précommande,
notamment dans les grandes enseignes
et les grands sites internet.
Si vous avez envie de le précommander,
je vous incite à le faire
parce que, du coup, ça permet d'améliorer
le référencement du livre
et ça permet aussi aux distributeurs
de mieux approvisionner les stocks
donc si vous souhaitez le précommander
faites-le, parce que ça m'aide et ça aide la visibilité du livre.
Sinon, à partir du 31 mai, il sera disponible
dans toutes les bonnes librairies,
n'hésitez pas à le demander
à votre librairie de quartier, s'ils ne l'ont pas.
Voilà, j'espère que le livre vous plaira
et puis, d'ici là, je vous dis à très bientôt
pour des nouvelles vidéos.